imagina que va llegando al gimnasio pero
estás llegando en un mal momento porque
hay un tipo todo musculoso a quien le
acaban de revocar la membresía al
gimnasio porque nunca limpiaba los
aparatos que usaba y dejaba todos
sudados él está muy enojado tan enojado
que agarra la puerta la arranca de donde
está y la avienta él no se da cuenta
hacia donde la avienta pero la avienta
justo en tu dirección vamos a llamarle a
esta velocidad bebé y qué hacen ustedes
cuando ven que viene esa puerta hacia
acá bueno a mí no me daría ninguna
vergüenza decir que me pongo a gritar
como loquita me pongo a gritar y me
gritó va a tener una frecuencia vamos a
decirle la frecuencia del grito mi
pregunta es que si yo voy a estar
gritando mi grito va a llegar hasta la
puerta y se va a reflejar de regreso
hacia donde yo estoy la pregunta es
a onda de sonido vamos a escuchar
después de que esta onda llegue aquí y
rebotó hacia nosotros escucharemos la
misma frecuencia con la que estuvimos
gritando escucharemos una frecuencia más
alta o una más baja este es un problema
bastante interesante vamos a resolver
qué es lo que voy a escuchar vamos a
usar la fórmula del efecto doppler ya
que es más apropiada para cuando hay
cosas en movimiento así que esto también
lo voy a hacer en dos partes primero voy
a imaginar que esta puerta es un
observador y yo quiero saber que
escucharía la puerta aunque bueno ya sé
que las puertas no escuchan nada pero
que escucharía la puerta si estuviera
moviéndose hacia acá qué frecuencia y
escucharía la puerta si fuera una
persona no va a ser ese grito va a ser
otra cosa vamos a llamarle efe puerta ya
que quiero saber qué es lo que escucha
la puerta usamos la fórmula del efecto
doppler y aquí vamos a tener la
frecuencia que es la frecuencia del
grito
esto va a multiplicar todo esto aquí
tengo un factor que es la velocidad del
sonido más menos para un observador en
movimiento va a ser la velocidad de este
observador en este caso es mi bebé que
es la velocidad de la puerta
recordemos que mi puerta es mi
observador entre comillas y yo quiero
conocer qué frecuencia le llega a ella
todo esto dividido entre la velocidad
del sonido y bueno cómo voy a saber si
voy a usar el más o el menos bueno una
forma que me ayudó mucho a recordar esto
es pensar si yo me estoy acercando hacia
la fuente de sonido pues la frecuencia
va a ser más grande por lo que aquí voy
a necesitar un numerador más grande
entonces voy a necesitar usar el más así
que la frecuencia que recibe esta puerta
tiene que ser mayor que la frecuencia
original entonces voy a dejar aquí el
más ya que quiero un numerador más
grande para que se cumpla esto y es así
como recuerdo si debo sumar o restar
y quizás se imaginen que con esto ya
acabamos si esta es la frecuencia que
llega a la puerta pues la va a reflejar
y me va a llegar igual pero no no es así
esta es la frecuencia que le llega a la
puerta pero ahora esta puerta la va a
irradiar esta puerta va a estar
comportándose como una bocina aquí hay
dos hacer su negocio y nuevo movimiento
ya que la puerta se está moviendo y ya
sabemos qué sucede con las bocinas en
movimiento vamos a tener otro
desplazamiento doppler aquí hay dos
desplazamientos dobles el primero es el
que está experimentando la puerta al
recibir esta frecuencia y el segundo es
cuando la puerta refleja ese sonido de
regreso así que ahora quiero la
frecuencia que voy a escuchar
la frecuencia que me llega y que es la
que finalmente voy a escuchar cuál es la
frecuencia que yo voy a escuchar pues va
a ser la frecuencia que recibió la
puerta que en este caso fue todo esto lo
que le llegó a la puerta oa mi bocina va
a hacer esto multiplicado por otro
desplazamiento o corrimiento vamos a
poner todo esto acá
y esto lo tengo que multiplicar por otro
factor que es el de tener una bocina en
movimiento aunque la puerta no es una
bocina se comporta como una ya que está
reflejando el sonido y se está moviendo
y este factor es la velocidad del sonido
como numerador y como denominador
tenemos la velocidad del sonido más o
menos la velocidad de mi bocina que en
este caso es la velocidad de mi puerta y
nuevamente tenemos que decidir cuál usar
el más o el menos bueno pues seguimos la
misma lógica yo sé que si las cosas se
acercan entre sí
la frecuencia va a aumentar entonces
tengo que elegir aquí la combinación que
me dé un número total más grande y si
tengo un operador aquí fijo pues mi
denominador va a tener que ser más
pequeño para que el número total sea más
grande entonces en este caso me voy a
quedar con el menos
voy a tener la velocidad del sonido
menos la velocidad de la puerta para que
aquí sea un número más pequeño en el
denominador lo elegí así porque aquí la
puerta se está acercando a la persona
estos dos están acercando por lo que su
frecuencia va a ser mayor y para
aumentar la frecuencia total tenemos que
tener un denominador pequeño aquí esta
frecuencia debe ser mayor por este
desplazamiento doppler esta es la
frecuencia que voy a escuchar la
frecuencia de mi grito multiplicada por
estos dos factores ya que vamos a tener
dos desplazamientos doppler aquí y
podríamos simplificar algunas cosas aquí
como estos bs pero seguiríamos teniendo
dos factores y eso es lo importante aquí
ya que tenemos dos corrimientos dobles
y ustedes me pueden decir oye esto es un
ejemplo muy tontito cuando voy a entrar
yo a un gimnasio y encontrarme aquí un
tipo musculoso enfurecido que arranque
las puertas y las ambiente
y si la verdad es un ejemplo muy tonto
pero aquí va un ejemplo del mundo real
imagínense que esto en lugar de que sea
una puerta es sangre sangre que está
fluyendo por alguna vena y tampoco es
que este fisicoculturista haya explotado
imagínense que en lugar de estar en el
gimnasio aquí tenemos una avena en donde
está fluyendo la sangre que está en
alguna parte de tu cuerpo y aquí en
lugar de estar yo gritando
desaforadamente tenemos una pieza de
equipo sensible y ese equipo va a
calcular la velocidad a la cual se está
moviendo esta sangre y esta es una forma
de hacerlo le enviamos ondas de sonido
aquí y la sangre las va a reflejar va a
regresar nos ondas de sonido también y
dependiendo de qué tanto cambio la
frecuencia podemos conocer la velocidad
a la que se está moviendo la sangre y
con esto sabemos la velocidad a la que
éste
están moviendo la sangre ya que vean que
esto depende de la velocidad del objeto
que se está moviendo en este caso
dijimos que era la velocidad de la
puerta pero ahora sería la velocidad de
la sangre oa lo mejor nosotros no somos
doctores si no somos policías y tenemos
un auto que está dándose a la fuga
este auto se dirige hacia nosotros y
nosotros queremos conocer a qué
velocidad se dirige hacia nosotros
tenemos un radar que usamos aquí y aquí
en lugar de usar ondas de sonido van a
ser ondas electromagnéticas pero con el
radar
yo voy a saber a qué velocidad se está
moviendo este auto
ya que las ondas de radar van a llegar
al auto y este las va a reflejar y con
el cambio de frecuencia voy a saber a
qué velocidad se encuentra este
corrimiento depende de la velocidad del
objeto en movimiento así que ya saben no
anden corriendo en las calles porque
pueden recibir alguna multa no sea que
los detecte el radar